good morning or a good afternoon
my name is roger kam i'm from mit
and i'm in the biological and mechanical
engineering departments
i'd like to describe some of the work
that we've been doing recently in
microphysiological systems
specifically in the context of
neurological disease
so to me a microphysiological system
uh has these attributes it would in some
way
recapitulate real organ form and
function
most of our work and a lot of the mo and
most of the micro
physiological systems are based on
microfluidic
technology that's been developed over
the past 15 years or so
most in many cases they should involve
3d culture
often multiple different organ types or
cell types
and a lot of the models are
patient-specific so for example we do a
lot of work in cancer
and we get biopsy specimens and then we
use patient-derived ips cells as well
i wouldn't say that these are
high-throughput systems but they are
relatively
they can be put onto platforms that have
say
40 experiments on on a 384 well
uh platform and most of the experiments
that i'm going to
or most of the platforms that i'm going
to describe today are amenable
to translation into that
level of throughput
our focus has been largely on developing
vascularized systems
most of what i talk about will have
vascular networks and be refusable
except for the last one that i that at
the end of my talk
and then finally in terms of
applications i think this audience knows
that
these could be used as disease models
they could be used in terms of
developing new approaches to therapy or
for drug screening
by way disclosure i'm a co-founder of
aim biotech
and a lot of the platforms that i'm
going to describe today
are basically of the design that you see
up in the
upper left hand corner the the pink
region corresponds to a region where the
gel can be inserted injected into the
system
and that could contain various cell
types the
aqua and blue channels correspond to
regions where
we have media access
there are variations on the design that
i'm going to show you today
but the basic concepts are here and when
we inject the gel
it's just constrained into that central
gel region by these posts
by surface tension pinning here's
another variation
on the design which we use more
generally for organoid systems where
we again we have the two media channels
we have a region
a gel region which is in the center and
then the
hole in the central region where we can
insert
either a different set of cells or an
organoid
so these systems have a variety of
advantages
and capabilities we can image using a
variety of different imaging techniques
we can sample the media at any
time point during the experiment going
through one of the
filling ports in the devices and
with that sampled media we can do any of
the typical biochemical or ohmic
analyses that you'd like to do and then
we can also do functional
assays so i'll talk a lot about
permeability measurements in the
vascular networks we can also look at
cell migration
and other characteristics that occur
during
normal disease processes
i'm going to quickly go through a couple
of movies just to give you an idea just
to orient you in terms of
the vascular networks that we develop
and how we can use those
again all of these are being done in a
device of the type that you see here
the first video that i show is going to
be of
the development of the vascular
structures by
self-assembly so we simply mix the
endothelial cells and oftentimes
fibroblasts
in with the gel solution we inject it
into
the central pink region of the device
and then over a period of about 24 to 48
hours
these form into networks that eventually
can become perfusable in the lower left
i'm not going to show this video but in
this case what we've done is we've taken
tumor cells that you that are shown in
green here
and we flow these into in the media
into the microvascular networks where
they can become stuck
they become activated and then they can
transmigrate out of the vasculature into
the surrounding tissue space
which is a gel matrix
the other two i'm going to go through so
let me just start with the movies
so this first one is the formation
uh with or without immune cells for uh
at least a week and probably more
this is just a to give you some idea of
the kind of
fluorescent microscopy that we
opens up a gap between two neighboring
and
this process generally takes about four
hours
in this case what we've done
into the vascular network from one of
our devices
event the image from the best from the
microvascular network
shows in uh in blue here because we
stained
uh collagen type four but you can see
that has a morphology
that that uh is very similar to what you
see in vivo
and by regulating not just the trans the
the channel the channel pressure which
allows us to regulate the intravascular
flow
we can also regulate the pressure
difference between inside the vessel
and the surrounding tissue space that
allows us to control the transparent
flow
just to give you some idea of what the
vascular wall looks like here's one type
junction
with a higher magnification up in the
corner uh showing a very tight
junction between the two endothelial
cells giving rise to low permeability
it's
almost at the level of the blood-brain
barrier in this case
and here we can also take these are em
images obviously we can look at uh
transport bib by vesicles across the
endothelial barrier
and some of this work has recently been
published
in this slide i'm going to talk about
the
measurements of vascular permeability
that we can make
and here we've done is generated our
three-dimensional network and we've
compared the results of that
using the same cells but in a transfer
system which is what
i think many of you probably are used to
using
when you measure the permeability or the
the leakiness of the
of the vasculature of the endothelium as
a function of molecular weight
with our 3d system we get the results
that are shown in the solid green
symbols
which agree very well with the in vivo
measurements which are the open green
symbols here
with the same cells in a 2d system we
get the solid orange symbols
and other 2d systems are shown in the
open symbols
so you can see there can be one to two
orders of magnitude difference
in the permeability that's with no
transmural flow if we generate a
transmural flow then the apparent
permeability goes
up with the pressure difference between
the
inside the vessel and outside the vessel
we can do that with various size various
molecular weight
dextrans for example and from these data
we can back out what the hydraulic
conductivity is
and also the reflection coefficient of
the vasculature
and again the green symbols are the
measurements here
corresponding closely with the animal
measurements
and somewhat lower than most of the 2d
measurements uh reflection coefficients
are what you'd expect
going from a small protein 4 kilo delta
index strand up to 150 kelvin dextrin
the reflection coefficients approach
about one
we can also make measurements even if
the
molecule of interest is non-fluorescent
um in this case what we've done is we
collected media
from the tissue port from the gel port
and analyzed it then using elisa
and then compared that to the
measurements that we make with a
fluorescent version of the same molecule
and you can see that both for albumin
and igg
we're getting normalized concentration
ratios this is concentration
intravascular divided by the i'm sorry
concentration outside the vessel divided
by concentration inside the vessel
for the two different proteins also
interestingly
if you look at the permeability the
apparent permeability for these two
molecules
what you find is that unlike the dextran
these are pressure independent
suggesting that these are both actively
transported
as we know that they are both albumin
and igg
and so most of them are being
transported through the cell
we've also looked at the transport of of
in this case two monoclonal antibodies
and two small molecule therapeutics
and again the concentration ratios are
pretty much what what you'd expect to
see
and they're consistent with uh um
measurements that
we've confirmed with with our sponsors
of this work with uh which is amgen
so i'm going to move on to the
blood-brain barrier these are just the
different pathways that
molecules use to get across the
endothelium
but the three different cell types that
are present in the blood-brain barrier
are shown here
the endothelial cells the pericytes
and the astrocytes the astrocyte and
feet which come in contact with the
vessels
and you can see we can either get
trans-cellular exchange or we can get
pericellular exchange
the model that we generated is is shown
here what we use is
um human ips derived endothelial cells
but then primary human brain parasites
and primary brain astrocytes
and what we do is we mix these three
cell types up into
a fibrin gel solution which we inject
into the central region of the
microfluidic device
and then these cells self-assemble into
the
the structures that that you observe in
the in vivo brain
uh here's one image that shows that
structure the green are the vascular
structures and the
and the pink are the astrocytes in this
case
we don't see the parasites because
they're not fluorescent
when we take that system and we measure
the permeability what we find is that
the co-culture with parasites or with
astrocytes
gives rise to a progressive reduction in
the permeability of the vascular
networks
which is what we'd expect to find in the
brain in fact
the that both the brain parasites and
astrocytes are are instrumental in terms
of
generating low permeabilities that in
our model system
uh become comparable to then what you
see in vivo
here are just a couple of electrum micro
electron micrographs of the vessels
again here showing um
what we occasionally see even in our in
our in
vitro systems is a seamless endothelial
cell junction
suggesting that these are extremely
tight
we can also just using false colors we
can look at interactions between
astrocytes
and the endothelial cell or in this case
the three cell types the astrocyte in
pink
the pericyte in red and the endothelial
cell in green
these images by the way were produced by
olga morzova
at harvard university in collaboration
again with amgen
so we're interested in seeing what was
giving rise to the tightness
the low permeability of our bbb model
so we looked at several different
proteins
the first three rows here are tight
junctional proteins and the last two are
are basement membrane proteins um
so this is just immunohistochemical
staining so you can see
at least qualitatively that as you go
from a monoculture to co-culture to a
tri-culture
system you get progressive higher
level progressively higher levels of
expression
of these tight junction proteins and
also of several basis
membrane proteins we did a more
extensive analysis using
rtpcr this is for all the cells
collectively in the system so in other
words it includes the endothelial cells
the pericytes and the astrocytes
but you can see it gives you some idea
how as you go
progressively in time from day zero up
to day seven
we get a progressive increase in the
expression level of these three
type junction proteins the ones
indicated by green
but also an increase relative increase
when we compare the
monoculture system to the co-culture and
the triculture system
some of these other proteins the genes
that i've highlighted and read here
are of interest because they happen to
be transporter proteins
that tend to be up regulated in the
brain bbb
um we went back and we redid some some
of the
rtpcr data this time we separated out
the endothelial cell so that we could
look
exclusively at the expression levels in
those
so again we're looking at the tight
junction or adherence junction proteins
those are the
ones in the first group and you can see
again
here we're comparing for example
the so these are the tight junction
proteins in the top and the transporter
proteins in the bottom
if we look for example comparing the
these are human brain microvascular
endothelial cells
um everything is normalized to the 2d
culture
we if we put these in 3d you can see
that the expression levels change
significantly
we can also show that
if we compare the ips cells as well
in the 2d culture most of these proteins
are expressed at relatively low levels
but then as we go to the three-key 3-d
co-culture system a lot of these
proteins become more highly regulated
notice that this is on the log scale so
we're talking about very large changes
and then finally we can also look at
comparison then between
the the primary human um microvascular
cells from the brain
and the ips derived endothelial cells
and what you see is very similar
expression pattern
and in fact in some cases the
uh the tight junction proteins are even
more highly expressed
uh in the ips cells uh once they're able
to signal with the
brain parasites and astrocytes
so why do we want to generate the
blood-brain barrier and
aside from looking at the transport
across the barrier we're also interested
in looking at the
metastasis of breast cancer for example
in this case
to to the brain so here again we
generate our blood brain barrier model
we introduce the cancer cells into the
system
and then we observe the extravasation
and this is just one sample of the
results
we've taken mda mb231 cells it's a
triple negative breast cancer
cell line uh either the parental cell
line
or cell a subpopulation of these cells
that preferentially
metastasize to to lung the lm
cells or the preferentially metastasized
brain the brm
cells and what we show here is that um
consistent with the fact that these
cells were isolated in mice
we see a higher extravasation rate
this is the percentage of cells that
extravasate across the bbb during the
24-hour period
it's higher when we have the astrocytes
present relative to when we have
either the ips alone or the ips and pcs
we took that one step further with
different cancer cell types here we
looked this is the breast cancer cell we
were just looking at
if we look at a549s which is lung cancer
cell line or the prostate carcinoma cell
line
we find that similar patterns of
behavior
where despite the fact that the cell
that the um bbb has a lower permeability
and has tighter junctions than than the
other cell types present
or than other vascular networks we get
higher levels of extravasation into the
surrounding tissue
we wanted to find out what factors were
being secreted by the cells it looked
like there was something that was
selected to be secreted by the astacites
that was influencing the rate of
extravasation
so we did a cytokine array and we
identified a few
cytokines that were up regulated in the
uh
co-culture system astrocytes and and the
cancer cells
but one in particular was ccl2 which was
upregulated five-fold higher
compared to the endothelial cells in the
tumor cells alone
so we focused on that and we first of
all
looked at i taking just our
monoculture system the vascular networks
derived just from the ips
drive dc's or the co-culture system
where we had the parasites
and then we added recombinant ccl2 and
what you see here is that
as we add an increasing level we get an
increase in the extravasation rate in
both cases
we could also do the opposite experiment
we could take the triculture
system including the pair the astrocytes
and as we block then uh introducing
a blocking antibody for ccl2 we got a
progressive reduction
in the extravasation rates and i'm not
going to be able to show these results
we've also looked at the molecule that
the massachee lab had identified as
being
partially responsible for the increased
extravasation rates to the brain
when we block that as well we get even
further reductions in our in-vitro model
so the in vitro model seems to be able
to recapitulate a lot of
the types of behavior that we see only
in mouse models otherwise
i'm going to move on to a different
model this is a monolayer model
looking at the interactions between the
vascular network and
and else alzheimer's disease neurons
this is a just a schematic on the left
hand side showing
the regions where we introduce uh in one
case
on the left-hand gel region let me start
from the left there's a media channel
first of all
on the far left the next channel is one
where we we introduce
the um genetically modified
uh es cells that are
engineered so that they overexpress
either a beta 40 or 42.
then there's an empty gel region and
then there's a channel that contains the
endothelial monolayer and what we're
looking at here
is how the a beta that secreted by the
neurons diffuses through the collagen
barrier
interacts with the endothelium and then
impacts that the function of that
barrier
so here are some of the results we're
looking at permeability first
for two different size dextrans and you
can see that the
cells that over express the a beta 40 or
42
that's with ad have a higher
permeability in other words are leakier
than the wild type cells for both
molecules
and also we can now start to demonstrate
that because of that increased leakiness
of the vascular barrier
if we add thrombin to the vasculature
that gives rise to a high rate of death
in the neurons especially in the ad
cells relative to the wild type
even without thrombin although we get
some
death of the alzheimer's cells
we also wanted to see how the a beta was
affecting the endothelial monolayer so
we looked at
both gene expression of these different
type junction proteins
um it also looked at it by at uh by
uh histochemist histochemical about
histochemistry analysis uh we could
identify for example
in some cases the a beta 40 or 42
actually accumulating on the outside
surface this is the endothelial
monolayer shown on the right hand side
and the green corresponds to the a beta
this is our more recent model where
we're combining the bbb
the blood-brain barrier vasculature
which is shown
here in green with a central region
where we can introduce the ren cells the
ad modified cells that overexpress a
beta
to to produce a more realistic model and
here you can see that the vasculature
actually
uh comes up very close to the neurons
and we get
much better exchange that's a model
that's just under development
finally what i'd like to do is talk a
little bit about
a model that we've developed a number of
years back and then have been further
developing with the health of biogen
and in this case uh we are looking
at a 3d human motor neuron
system a motor unit on a chip
this just shows the chip in schematic
form
there are four experiments on one of
these chips uh
the the works are shown here where on
the right hand side we can introduce
uh ips derived
skeletal muscle cells that form around
posts
separately we differentiate the
endothelial cells i'm sorry the neuron
the motor neurons and then we can
insert them over on the left hand side
this shows it the process a little bit
more schematically
we first introduce the muscle cells they
coalesce around these posts
uh then once the motor neurons are
differentiated we can insert them in
in a collagen gel over on the left-hand
side
and then over the course of about these
motor neurons
extend neurites and they penetrate into
the muscle and they innervate it
i should mention that all the cells are
either ips or es derived
and they're also all modified to become
up to be optogenetic
so all we have to do is shine a light on
these motor neurons on the left-hand
side
and then they can activate the muscle
and we can see muscle contraction
with the muscle contraction because the
posts are actually flexible we can
we can back out what the force of
contraction is under these different
conditions
and this is what the motor unit looks
like the motor
neurons are on the left hand side the
blue is dappy the green shows the
neurites and then the red on the right
hand side is the muscle
in these images the first image on the
left is a single slice and a confocal
image
these are all at day 14 of the
co-culture and you can see the neurites
extending into the muscle
and then forming the neuromuscular
junctions
and we know that the junctions are made
because we can activate the neurons
either
using glutamic acid or optogenetically
and we get muscle contraction which we
can use then again
as a means of measuring the force
this shows what happens the blue image
in the upper right hand corner
means the light is being shown on the
neurons
and as i say from that we can measure
the force
we've looked at this in terms of drug
screening we've just
proof of principle we took two drugs the
pseudonym and rapamycin
both of which act to increase autophagy
that are in either phase one or phase
two clinical trial
here in the first graph we're looking at
the force of contraction of the muscle
the muscle i should i should point out
is the same in both the als and the
healthy systems
only the motor neurons are derived from
an als patient
uh despite that what we find is that the
muscle contractile force
in the far right here on day 14 the
light gray box corresponds to the
healthy motor unit
the black box corresponds to the als
motor unit so you can see there's a
already a loss of function in the muscle
which is recovered partly by the use of
the
one or both drugs
we can also look at it added in terms of
the morphology of the system
you see on the left here and then also
in terms of the the
uh cell death uh in the in the muscle
cluster
uh which is very low in the healthy
system is quite high with
als but then it's recovered again
through the therapies
suggesting that this platform could be
used for drugs cleaning
so with that i'd like to end but i need
to acknowledge
certainly all my collaborators the
postdoctoral researchers or visiting
scientists that did the work that
that i just presented especially
giovanni offidoo and tatsuya osaki
and yujin shin all postdocs in my lab
who did most of the
neurological work and graduate students
marco campisi was instrumental in
developing the blood-brain barrier model
as was
cynthia hajjal our different sources of
funding
in the rest of my lab thank you very
much
and i look forward to seeing the
questions that you have